[Music]
when we walk to the town petorca and urban
in trees colorful profiles 6 gb the war
back for workforce cel
some tremendous avocado plantations and
that was drying everything and that was because of the
appearance that there is here they can be seen down there
towards the sea  that in times of
abundance of water in those years that were
of abundance of water before cultivating
in the hills with grasses
baby hard knock out is to do two
shows cancer world style list
injustice can be seen in the landscape and it can be seen in  the
landscape also the inequality in
access to water the water is never free from the
sky that I am
and they have made it a commercial good
and day the water is not for everyone
[Music]
good in your petorca in central chile
weaver smooth pressure philosopher and
lawyer  mobile mind and for europe in it
said that it is not against the pikes right on
the side of the screen aviation artist
villages tower current and tracking in
water until every day
l
[Music]
the drought has always been the seq  uía will
always be a semi-arid place I
think we have said it I don't know
who is here
shout works traction rights
and we know exploration day and action and
enjoy candy traders private property
[Music]
and
but from the year 80 onwards
they came to promote green gold and
really from there the hills began to be planted
to build a
lot of deep wells
[Music]
but people even said of people who
helped open the eyes of the neighbors
but they never thought that this was going to
harm us
many have already gone bankrupt they have
lost because of the  frost from the
lack of the high water requirement
that the crop has but those who survive
are the large investors who have
been able to buy lease water rights
and that they have been buying the lands
also of those who have gone to auction
of
industrial control systems food alone generates
order eha family jobs a contiguity
population of mine a million
of down side is to shape account for
more they owe them percent of war with
'champions  ' it
comes from the river because there is a
water-based coffee context and there is a whole
competition for water who gets
to the water first
and it happened to us that there was so much
water extractivism that it was burned in
the river and when the river ran out we did not
forget  what
the communities are living through are its
inhabitants,
we irrigate with water from the canal that has already
dried up again in the canal and now we have
to irrigate with water from wells and my
husband has already deepened it quite a bit
[Music]
and
but not
being  bad and above animal
or down below and one goes looking for
water
[Music]
georg with my grandson but they always
inside because
a little more
but you still
have to do
all this that is  here
I use this it comes out here it
waters
here it goes everyone also wants to go home and we
reuse the water from the silver washing machine
that when I pointed the ball at
them water was falling here from the
light
[Music]
from
wherever you are
[Music]
we know that  the human right to water
has to be mandated and be
directly applied by the constitution
[Music]
you have a law that I believe
that we have to change the
property or patrimonial regime that is
on the side of the day and that this  frivolizing
water, which does not mean taking away the right
to water, you cannot, like me, have a
right to water that is in perpetuity,
as currently stated in the water code,
because water is not perpetual,
water is dynamic, it is
universal hydrodynamics, because the people who  they live
at what time of the flowerbed they have
installed it I was a dry tear of
indignation because they see how the neighbor
waters while they have to wait for
the water to change the bleach
[Music]